[Music]
you know it's all fun and games on
social media until somebody says check
the scoreboard which is what a fan did
with Antonio Brown yesterday Antonio
Brown engaging with fans and then one of
them posted an image of juju Smith
Schuester with the designation that he
was the Steelers 2018 MVP oh that's a
raw nerve and that got a Antonio Brown
to respond he went all in on juju Smith
Schuester at that point boy fumbled the
whole postseason in the biggest game of
the year everyone went blind too busy
making guys famous not enough reality
these days I don't know what any of that
means but I do know that it means this
it's a shot at juju Smith Schuester and
that sparked an interesting afternoon on
Twitter because to his credit Chris juju
Smith Schuster was not taking any more
crap from Antonio Brown he tweeted his
way out of Pittsburgh Antonio
you've won you got out you got your
money
shut up about the Steelers and move on
there is nothing good that comes from
you taking shots at anyone in Pittsburgh
now that you're not in Pittsburgh
anymore no I mean it definitely doesn't
does him no good I don't understand it
it's a really a bad look I mean it makes
him look a little bit insecure there's
no other way to say it about Antonio
Brown I mean it's obviously showing the
cards that there was jealousy and all
the things that we talked about at the
end of the regular season last season
where the Antonio Brown felt
disrespected he was bothered by the fact
that juju Smith Schuster was named team
MVP and listen deuter's miss Schuster is
right he's been nothing but supportive
of Antonio Brown with all the issues
Antonio Browns had off the field the
last two years
juju Smith Schuster has been in this
corner from the get-go even when things
got ugly okay with Antonio Brown he was
still very supportive of him so yeah it
is not a good look for Antonio Brown and
I you know again Antonio Bryant I just
don't understand it and to say okay yeah
Judy Smith Schuster fumbled and the
biggest moment add fuel to that fire
Smith Schuster's admitted it
he's get he and really Antonio Brown he
just can't talk about you know
performances and big games because
really arguably the next week was every
bit as a big game and you weren't even
there that week to get ready and prepare
for the game and then weren't allowed to
play and you want to blame the Steelers
because they didn't let you play because
you broke like nine team rules but
somehow that's the Steelers thought so
I'm on Team juju with this one all the
way and and look the logic is very
simple and we now have the evidence the
Steelers named juju smushed Shuster the
MVP that week the players became aware
of it on Tuesday on Wednesday Antonio
Brown had his blow up and walked out of
practice and didn't show up again wanted
to come in and play on Sunday and Mike
Tomlin told him no and it's clear now
that it was that jealousy that very
basic human emotion one of the set is it
one of the seven deadly sins I don't
know but it reared its ugly head here
and it got it got Antonio Brown to a
boiling point and it still exists it's
still there the resentment and the
jealousy of the guy who was gonna take a
Antonio Browns place and now is taking
his place in Pittsburgh because Brown
wanted out of town and some of the
things that Smith Shuster said in
response to Brown all I ever did was
show that man love and respect from the
moment I got to the league I was
genuinely happy for him to when he got
traded to Oakland with a big contract
now he takes shots at me crazy how that
big ego has got to be to take shots at
people who show you love that's Judy
Smith Schuster and and I just it really
is astounding to me and it makes me
wonder Chris how much of this routine
that we saw from Antonio branch anywhere
in February and into March before he was
traded how much of it really was
engineered and calculated and how much
of it was just Antonio Brown being
Antonio Brown and you know it's not like
he won a strategic game that he played
he just was being him the Steelers were
gonna move on without him anyway and it
looks like he came out of it with this
carefully crafted victory when you know
like like I've said time and again maybe
the Steelers just wanted him out Ben
Roethlisberger may have said I want him
out and what he said on social media
really didn't matter yeah well yeah
maybe it maybe it didn't
either way I mean he hasn't handled
himself right or correctly since the
season ended I I don't really understand
you know again what what he accomplishes
by taking these shots at juju Smith
Schuster you know I guess the big thing
I would talk about with Antonio Brown
and his issues here you know again it's
just showing you that he's a handful and
that the Oakland Raiders gonna have to
deal with the guy who if you don't get
him the ball and he's not comfortable
and his egos not being placated - you
better watch out it's just more evidence
and I think the big thing to me again
where I go back to this you know here we
are Pittsburgh still having to hear
about Antonio Brown I just don't
understand why they let him out the door
so easily I don't I understand that they
wanted to be done with it
but I want to argue at the same time you
know again it kind of makes it look like
you know you're letting the bad guys run
the show they're in Pittsburgh oh I want
to get out I'm out of here
you know I think Pittsburgh could have
sent a stronger message to their team
and the rest of the NFL cuz we've heard
that teams are not happy the way the
Pittsburgh Steelers handled the Antonio
Brown situation if they drew more of a
concrete line or a line in the sand here
to say no we're not just gonna let you
go out the door and break team rules and
act like a fool and get whatever you
want that to me is also part of this
issue Antonio Brown just gotten Bolden
by what he did he feels like he's the
man I mean he's making comments I want
to show people how to do better business
even though I think this is the only
time in the history of the league this
is gonna happen I mean they really
placated to his ego more there and I
guess that's where I blame Pittsburgh in
this whole situation to a degree as well
and that's why I can see other teams
being upset with the Steelers for yeah
yeah and allowing this precedent to be
created where players think they have
power and control now and what it's
going to require is someone to stand up
to a player like the Eagles did in 2005
with Terrell Owens to push the balance
back in the other direction now the
Raiders gonna have to deal with this guy
and and you dealt with Jon Gruden if
you're Jon Gruden yeah his first meeting
with Antonio Brown when they're allowed
to meet when they're allowed to converse
as part of the off season program
what does Gruden's say to Antonio Brown
based on your experience my experience
is I don't think he's gonna say much as
far as like okay you need to do this or
do that I think more of what Jon Gruden
is gonna do with Antonio Brown is play
the role of of salesman he's he's gonna
sell the offense to Antonio Brown he's
gonna sell the fact that the offense is
gonna be orchestrated around Antonio
Brown he's gonna sell the fact that man
I'm gonna get you lots of touches and
you're gonna be towards the top of the
league and receptions and yards and all
of those types of things and then he's
gonna sell his offense in general to
Antonio Brown like I've told you in the
past where he's gonna show Jerry Rice
runs running certain Jon Gruden plays
from the years with Joe Montana and he's
gonna show Tim Brown and all these other
famous receivers who have been in the
Jon Gruden West Coast like system and
show Antonio Brown listen this is gonna
be you for my offense and he's gonna
hope that Antonio Brown will just buy in
from that standpoint and be a part of
the team but he's not gonna make like a
hey I need you to be on time and do all
that type of stuff I don't envision that
going down at least in the first few
conversations with Gruden Antonio Brown
and my experience Mike if you're a
teammate of brown now in Oakland yeah
I'm trying to figure out how you react
to this and do you tiptoe on eggshells
with him are you concerned about what
kind of guy he's gonna be
is he gonna turn his wrath on you at
some point yeah like I do you have to
defer to him to do do we have to vote
him team MVP preemptively so we don't
have an issue with him you know right
and I keep coming I keep coming back to
Derrick Carmen I I'm telling you what
when it went in the Larry Fitzgerald
comments from March when he said that
Antonio Brown may not realize how good
he has it and that Antonio Brown could
find out the hard way that not having
Ben Roethlisberger makes it harder to be
as good as he's been if he thinks he's
open and car doesn't throw it if he is
open and car throws it and it doesn't
hit him in-stride or if he's got a you
know lunge or jump or gets blown up
because the ball is placed in the spot
where a safety can legally and cleanly
hit Antonio Brown in a way he hasn't
been hit since he was hit by Vaughn says
Burfict I mean if that kind of stuff
happens
it's not gonna be Browns fault it's not
gonna be Gruden's fault it's gonna be
Derek cars fault I think he's the guy
who needs to be the most concerned by
everything we've seen from Antonio Brown
from the end of the season until
yesterday with the assault against you
juice miss Schuester yeah no I listen
you your question about how our players
gonna receive Antonio Brown are they
gonna tiptoe around him how is it gonna
play out in the locker room you know
listen I mean Antonio Brown obviously
has the social media fix I mean I to me
it's it's mind blown emoji on why he's
even worried about answering some guy
who says juju Smith Schuester was a team
MVP and he feels like he has to respond
to that guy on Twitter to me when you're
Antonio Brown come on just take the
loved ones and respond to the ones that
are all loving move on be positive go
forward but teams the players in the
locker room I mean know Antonio Brown
has been anointed somewhat king of the
locker room right off the bat I mean one
players are gonna know damn I don't want
to really say anything even close to
insensitive about Antonio Brown on
social media so they're never even that
nothing is gonna get close to negative
there but two they've seen the way and
John Gruden's acted since he signed
Antonio Brown the the players have also
seen the fact that Oh three years fifty
million dollars on top of that so they
know where he stands in the pecking
order and money talks a lot of the times
in the locker room and when there's
money on a certain player the rest of
the locker room knows man can't mess
with this guy he's kind of king in the
squad right now and that's when Antonio
Brown is for John Gurdon the Raiders
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports